ex New York Governor Andrew Cuomo says
Joe Biden should face Democratic primary
so Cuomo has I think $5 million left in
his pack and I'm not sure he is going
away Andrew KO and I'm not sure he's
happy about the fact that everybody got
rid of him out of nowhere at a time
where everybody thought he was going to
be the next president going up against
Trump Andrew KOMO the former New York
Governor has called for Democratic
challenge against Biden in 2024 and I
think there should be a Democratic
primary Kom criticized Biden for
distancing himself from allegations
against him referring to the Tera read
case and expressed doubts about Biden's
strength as candidate saying I don't
know that candidate Biden is the
strongest candidate we can put up
frankly I doubt it he urged the
Democratic party to engage with voters
on a different level emphasizing the
need for a affirmative strategy to win
elections Koma also criticized the
slogan defund the police calling it The
Three dumbest words ever uttered by the
Democratic party
Tom uh Andrew cromo says if you're
looking for somebody else I'm right here
that's basically what what he just said
and he did it by providing some facts
and some basis and some foundation for
his argument why don't we have a
democratic process and have candidates
and an Open Primary do we think Biden is
the best I don't think so let's have a
primary and uh by the way he he
announces one of his campaign pledges
Pat I think defund the police is one of
the three dumbest words ever uttered by
the Democratic party it sounds like a
guy who wants to look like a moderate
doesn't it this is Andrew cromo saying I
think we need open primary and ladies
and gentlemen I'm right here I I will be
in that's what he's saying you think he
had the chance though Pat like in all
honesty I think I think the the the
table's already set for like it's
obvious in our face Pat Uh Biden is not
going to run there's absolutely no way
that he's going to run and I I
definitely think uh Nome and I'm telling
you man when Roger Stone said it he said
it a while ago he goes don't be
surprised if Michelle Obama comes out of
nowhere and he goes take that to the
bank he goes remember I'm the first one
that said it I I just I know obviously I
don't trust them I think they have
something up their sleeves that's G to
be coming but Pat there's no there's no
way they picked who they wanted the
swamp knows who they want I mean they
wouldn't Biden's the perfect stay there
we'll tell you what to say your handlers
will moove you here and if God forbid he
dies or he falls and breaks his neck
guess what kamla is right there and
she's she's one of them what do you can
I can I do a little um you know I don't
know remember remember that idiot that
used to be on late night TV Cleo you
would call her and she would tell
Fortune let me be a little fortune
teller how does Governor exg Governor
andw Cuomo feel about watching the semi
anointing of Gavin Nome this guy comes
from a family that was a pillar of the
democratic party he led a blue State he
led you know a policy that the Democrat
the party felt was beloved Andrew Cuomo
was a Statesman and a leader in that
party and now he's looking half all the
way across the United States to the
anointing of a relative rookie in Gavin
Nome I gotta believe Pat that there
maybe is a little bit of athletic um
jealousy here going on because I happen
to think Andrew Cuomo if you is a is a
Democrat a I think he's formidable I
think the S Nome is formidable I think
they I'd love to see Cuomo in there but
if you look at the resume of dirt
there's not a single person that's going
to run at that level that's not going to
have dirt yeah if you man if you compare
dirt of Andrew Koma versus Bon Bon's
killing him the score is 71 to one
touchdown okay is what the scores Bon's
against Andrew K so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here